[Musik]
grüß euch mein name ist hauptmann fuchs
ich bin der technisch auf sie und kraft
auf ist hier vom jägerbataillon 17
straße wir stehen hier vom mannschaft
transportpanzer bandur evolution das ist
eines von 34 fahrzeugen ihren straßen
mit nächsten jahr sollen weitere 30
stück hier in straße zu laufen
der haupt verwendungszweck dieses
fahrzeuges ist der geschützte mannschaft
und transport
das fahrzeug wird angetrieben von einem
sechszylindermotor mit 8,9 liter hubraum
der firma kamenz turbo aufgeladenen
bringt es dass dieses triebwerk auf 455
ps und über 1600 newtonmeter drehmoment
das fahrzeug liegt 18,3 bommel hat eine
breite von 268 eine höhe von 290 über
der wasserstation und eine länge von 7
metern
die kraftübertragung erfolgt vom mutter
aus über 1 1 über eine wandlerautomatik
auf alle drei achsen alle drei achsen
können zu 100 prozent gesperrt werden
des weiteren verfügt das fahrzeug über
eine reifendruck regelanlage die ist dem
fahrer ermöglicht bei allen fahr
zuständen den reifendruck an den
untergrund anzupassen
diese möglichkeit um die kombination mit
der 100-prozentigen sperrwirkung und des
niedrigen schwerpunkt des des fahrzeuges
ermöglichen eine enorme
geländegängigkeit das fahrzeug es weiter
weiteres merkmal dieses fahrzeug ist ist
das 360 grad kamera system das sich aus
mehreren kameras rund um das fahrzeug
zusammensetzt das besteht aus einer tag
sicht kamera und einer wärmebildkamera
die mannschaft kann somit rund um das
fahrzeug blicken auch wenn die lücken
komplett geschlossen sondern also nicht
nur über die winkel spiegeln sondern
auch über das kamerasystem
somit ist auch das fahren mit
geschlossene lücke unter zuhilfenahme
der kameras möglich
[Musik]
und von hinten an wie schon angesprochen
der haupt verwendungszweck ist der
geschützte mannschaftstransporter
deshalb haben wir zusätzlich zur stahl
wanne zusatz panzerung am fahrzeug
angebracht dass ich rund um das fahrzeug
erstreckt dieses verbundmaterial schützt
zusätzlich die wanne vorgeschossen
arminen explosionen
sollte es dennoch zu an durch tritt
indes kampf um innere kommen verfügt das
fahrzeug über eine brand unterdrückung
anlage diese werbung es dann von innen
anschauen
deshalb kommt es mit ins fahrzeug wir
steigen ein über die heckklappe im
innenraum sehen wir jetzt die sensoren
der brand unterdrückung anlage diese
erkennen wenn ein geschoss oder teile
einer mine in den innenraum vordringen
sollten und lässt über die hallen
gasbehälter hall um gas ausströmen in
den innenraum somit wie der sauerstoff
aus der wand gedrückt und es wird
verhindert dass treibstoffe
schmierstoffe oder zeit ladungen
explosionsartig umsetzen können
um die mannschaft von ihnen auch beim
ihnen auffallen weiters zu schützen
haben ja mir sicher dass heißt es sind
nicht starr mit der wand verbunden
sondern flexibel aufgehängt dadurch
ergibt sich eine gewisse dämpfung
arminen auffahrunfall
des weiteren verfügt das fahrzeug über
eine abc anlage das bedeutet wenn man
mit luken dicht fährt kann man die abc
anlage aktivieren und über den abc
luftfilter wir saubere luft von außen
angesaugt es entsteht ein gewisser
überdruck in der wanne und die der
überdruck wird dann über diverse
öffnungen nach außen gedrückt und somit
hat man immer saubere luft im kampf um
die mannschaft des pandur setzt sich
zusammen aus den kraftfahrer der
befindet sich ganz links vorne in der
wanne den bordschützen der befindet sich
links dahinter
der kommandant befindet sich rechts
vorne im kampf um die besatzung im
normalfall aktion daten jetzt aufgrund
der klage nur vier soldaten befinden
sich hinten im mannschaftsraum
so und jetzt abschließend schauen wir
uns die waffen station am fahrzeug an
die haupt bewaffnung des parcours ist
das 12,7 mm smg aufgrund der waffe
station ist dieses mgv stabilisiert die
wochenstation verfügt zusätzlich über
eine nebenleitung messer eine taxis
kamera und eine wärmebildkamera die es
dem fahrzeug auch ermöglicht vollkommen
nach machtkampf tauglich zu sein
so jetzt hat es im großen ganzen alles
über das fahrzeug gehört jetzt geht's ab
ins gelände
[Musik]